[Aplausos]
buenos días mucha gente que bueno que
están aquí quiero dar las gracias por
darme pues unos minutos para compartir
con ustedes unas ideas sobre industria
4.0 que es un tema que nos toca vivir
actualmente
bueno antes de iniciar quiero
presentarles a una persona muy especial
algunas personas públicos la conocen es
maría del socorro graciela elizondo
hinojosa la mayoría no la deben conocer
seguramente pero yo sí porque ella es mi
abuelita mi abuelita coco como le
decimos mis hermanos y yo mi abuelita
coco ella es originaria de los aldamas
nuevo léon y ella fue maestra en la
escuela primaria allí en el pueblo
entonces para la época de mi abuelita
pues tuvo un gran privilegio de haber
podido estudiar y ser maestra
pasan algunos años y ella decide emigrar
aquí a monterrey y empieza a trabajar en
el conmutador del periódico el porvenir
alrededor de mil novecientos cincuenta y
tantos y en aquella época los
conmutadores pues eran de clavija que se
necesitaba una persona hiciera las
conexiones al momento de hacer una
llamada
todo muy bonito pero alrededor de 1931
la tecnología avanzó y el periódico el
porvenir compra un moderno sistema cross
bar que básicamente suple a las personas
que hacían las interconexiones y hace
esas interconexiones de manera
automática por obvias razones pues el
trabajo que desempeña mi abuelita poco
ya no era necesario entonces ella
decidió tomar otros caminos y deja de
lado la industria de las
telecomunicaciones
pero si hacemos un ejercicio de
imaginación y nos cuestionamos que
hubiera pasado o qué opciones hubiera
tenido mi abuelita si yo hubiera querido
seguir en la industria creciente de las
telecomunicaciones
tenía dos sopas o aprender o perder
entonces eso pone nada nuevo somos seres
humanos no tenemos garras no somos
fuertes no somos rápidos si no tenemos
cerebro y capacidad de adaptación
así es como el ser humano ha
evolucionado y siempre ante la
disyuntiva de aprender o perder y eso es
verdad y ha sido verdad para las
revoluciones industriales desde la
primera segunda y tercera
en la primera revolución industrial por
ahí de mil setecientos ochenta y tantos
pues pasamos de hacer las cosas a mano a
hacer las cosas de manera mecanizada y
creo que es obvio que muchos empleos
concretos se perdían el ejemplo más
clásico de la revolución industrial o
son los telares antes para hacer un
tramo de tela pues tenía que alguna
persona hacer ahora hay una máquina que
lo hace lo hace muy rápido entonces
claro ese trabajo particular de la
persona que operaba el telar se perdió
pero se crearon para soportar toda esta
maquinaria pues un montón de nuevos
empleos era necesario que alguien creara
esas máquinas que alguien construyera
esas máquinas que las operara que les
diera su mantenimiento entonces como ven
se crean más empleos de los concretos
que se perdieron cuando uno logra ver la
imagen completa no david pixel pero
además de eso se crean nuevos negocios
la tela antes era muy cara porque se
hacía a mano pero ahora que se hacía de
manera masiva pues basa su costo
entonces la industria textil pues tuvo
un boom se crean nuevos negocios nuevos
empleos seguramente y ahora si la gente
empezó a pensar seriamente en ser
diseñador de moda porque ahora ya había
tela barata
segunda revolución industrial vimos algo
similar la diferencia es que empezó a
todo a producirse en masa pero
nuevamente se necesitaban personas con
un set muy particular de destrezas y
habilidades para dar frente a esas
nuevas necesidades gente que creara
construyera operará mantuviera y nuevos
negocios
un desarrollo tecnológico muy importante
la segunda versión industrial fue el
modelo t el carro y pues en ese momento
ya ahora había carros baratos que
permitían a los negocios poder tener
acceso a materias primas que estaban muy
lejos y poder transportarlas entonces
también se detonan nuevos negocios
la tercera revolución industrial que fue
más o menos 100 años después de la
segunda es la transición entre hacer las
cosas por máquinas pero máquinas
operadas por personas ahora a máquinas
que son operadas de manera automática a
través de todos los procesos de
automatización claro se ocupan personas
que programen esas automatizaciones y
aquí vemos un escenario similar si
ocupaban personas que crearan
construyeran operarán y mantuvieran
todos estos sistemas automatizados los
robots los pistones los plc es para los
están formalizados con ese concepto o
las computadoras industriales de hecho
alrededor de esta época se crean
carreras nuevas que no existían como la
carrera de ingeniero en electrónica y
automatización entonces nuevamente vemos
como claro se pierden algunos concretos
algunos empleos de manera concreta pero
se crean muchos más no creo que no sé si
sepan pero la cantidad de empresas que
hay aquí en monterrey de automatización
es enorme y todas esas personas antes
trabajaban en alguna empresa pero por el
cambio tecnológico ahora ellos pudieron
poner su propia empresa
entonces empezamos a ver beneficios como
consecuencia de estos cambios
tecnológicos y la cuarta revolución
industrial que es en la que vivimos o la
que estamos iniciando uno debe ser
diferente a las tres anteriores al menos
en el sentido de que se ocupan destrezas
y habilidades nuevas pero si hay un par
de características diferentes número uno
la rapidez con la que suceden las cosas
entre la primera segunda y tercera
revolución industrial hay alrededor de
100 años
la cuarta revolución industrial está
separada 40 50 años de la tercera quiere
decir que alguien que estudia una
profesión pues difícilmente va a tener
conocimientos vigentes al final
y la complejidad los problemas o las
soluciones que se demandan en esta nueva
revolución industrial son mucho más
complejos
entonces la cuarta revolución industrial
es el cambio de máquinas que operan
automáticamente programadas por personas
a máquinas que operan igual
automáticamente pero autogestionadas ya
no ocupas a una persona que esté ahí
sino la misma máquina va haciendo su
trabajo
y ahí empezamos a ver la complejidad de
las soluciones que se requieren
industria 4.0 para lograr este objetivo
de autogestión de las máquinas requiere
que toda la información de los procesos
esté disponible en tiempo real para
lograr eso ocupas que todas las personas
todas las cosas estén conectadas para
analizar todos esos datos procesarlos y
hacer que las máquinas o los procesos se
autogestiona para lograr esto pues
industria 4.0 o la cuarta versión
industrial usan ciertos tipos de
tecnologías que son muy características
y hablamos de cosas como materiales
avanzados inteligencia artificial
manufactura aditiva otro de printing
entonces son disciplinas muy distintas
que no caen solamente en alguna
profesión en particular y es aquí donde
queda claro la complejidad de los
problemas de 4.0 4.0 no es algo distante
como comenté es algo actual y lo vemos
por ejemplo en la realidad de la
producción de un nuevo vehículo
diseñar simular construir o simular la
construcción todo eso involucra
tecnologías como robótica inteligencia
artificial simulación realidad virtual y
aumentada infinidad de disciplinas que
convergen para hacer un producto pero
industria 4.0 también tiene cosas
triviales o al menos más cercanas al
individuo como podemos ver el termostato
de un clima central no sé si alguien
conoce el dispositivo nest o alguien
tiene en su casa una aspiradora
robotizada entonces son dispositivos que
requieren diferentes tecnologías y que
son una muestra de lo que es industria
4.0 ahorita ya
entonces estos cambios tecnológicos
están relacionados con industria 4.0
pues modifica en la industria como dice
pero otra particularidad de industria
4.0 es que no se queda ahí si no nada
más va a afectar una industria como fue
el caso de las telecomunicaciones con el
ejemplo que le di a mi abuelita sino que
industria 4.0 afecta a todas las áreas
del quehacer humano afecta también el
área médica empezamos a ver robots o
mucha interrelación entre ingeniería y
medicina afecta cómo se le da
mantenimiento a esas máquinas que
producen las cosas los procesos de
construcción para los que sean
ingenieros civiles afecta a la
agricultura ya no es lo mismo que hace
50 o 100 años afecta la manera en la que
se resuelven los problemas la capacidad
de procesamiento los celulares ahora es
monstruosa la manera en la que hacemos
comercio ya muy pocas personas usan
efectivo y hay infinidad de plataformas
para poder hacer compras y afectan a la
sociedad el tejido social como lo
conocemos ahora tiene actores nuevos
cuantos interactúan de manera cotidiana
con asistentes de inteligencia
artificial como citi de google
alexa es algo común hasta
chiquitos platican con ellos entonces es
un integrante nuevo de nuestra sociedad
entonces industria 4.0 al igual que las
otras revoluciones pues tiene su set muy
particular de destrezas y habilidades
que se adquieren se siguen ocupando
ingenieros pero ahora ocupan saber
marketing y se ocupan licenciados en
marketing pero que sepan un poco de
ingeniería se necesita un poco de
conocimiento de las diferentes áreas
claro no podemos dejar de lado que va a
pasar lo mismo que las otras
revoluciones algunos empleos ya no van a
ser requeridos como le pasó a mí ahorita
poco sin embargo a pesar de que hay
estudios serios que dicen que alrededor
de una quinta parte de la población
económicamente activa va a tener que
cambiar de trabajo porque ya no posee
las destrezas y habilidades necesarias o
porque ese empleo ya no tiene sentido
verdad no hay por qué tener miedo al
respecto porque nuevamente como humanos
estamos en la misma disyuntiva que
cuando nos bajamos del árbol o aprendes
o pierdes
entonces históricamente tenemos que
sentir seguridad y lo podemos ver en los
números siempre que ha habido
transiciones tecnológicas se crean
nuevos negocios nuevas oportunidades
piensen en las empresas que están
mostradas aquí algunas de ellas no
existen hace diez años o hace quince
años y todas ellas ahora son las
empresas más poderosas que existen en el
planeta y si analizamos un poquito
detalle vemos una característica que
tienen todas esas y es que el valor de
estas empresas está en los datos los
datos los datos en la primera revolución
industrial el valor estaba en tener
máquinas en la segunda en tener
procedimientos para usar estas máquinas
de manera más eficiente en la tercera en
cómo automatizar los procesos para hacer
todo perfecto just-in-time como se dice
en manufactura
en la cuarta revolución industrial en la
que vivimos es datos el valor de la
información
y cuando pensamos en eso pues cualquiera
de los que está sentado aquí puede
generar datos cualquier lo que está
sentado aquí puede utilizar datos
entonces la cuarta revolución industrial
tiene el potencial para democratizar la
generación de la riqueza ya no es
necesario que ahora te contraten la
empresa papá y te cuide a lo largo de tu
vida como económicamente activa sino
ahora tú puedes decidir hoy os voy a
hacer y hoy quiero ganar dinero es la
decisión del individuo de hacer algo y
ya no necesita a toda una organización
para lograrlo
entonces el dilema de aprender o perder
en realidad del ser humano lo tiene bien
resuelto solamente nos queda aprender
pero la industria 4.0 en la cuarta
revolución industrial hay tres
características de este proceso de
aprendizaje número uno el aprendizaje
debe ser constante como todo ahora
sucede muy rápido no basta con ir a la
que ir a la universidad estoy una
carrera y listo el concepto de
aprendizaje a lo largo de la vida es
algo real en este mundo de la cuarta
opción industrial toda la vida hay que
estar aprendiendo cosas nuevas cosas
nuevas cosas nuevas
aprender o perder
segundo criterio la
transdisciplinariedad antes estudiaba si
eras especialista en algo eso ya no es
suficiente
después dijiste bueno me junto con otros
expertos de otras áreas y eres
multidisciplinar industria 4.0 la cuarta
revolución industrial requiere
individuos transdisciplinarios qué
quiere decir pues que yo tengo mi
especialidad pero también sé un poco de
a b c o de y esto me va a permitir
atacar la complejidad de los problemas
que presenta industria 4.0 y el tercer
criterio del aprendizaje en este mundo
es la conciencia social
todos usan weiss o alguna plataforma
similar como google maps debe de
quedarle muy claro que si todos los
demás en la ciudad no comparten su
ubicación no comparten su velocidad no
avisan dónde hay un choque estas
plataformas no funciona el beneficio
individual solamente se puede garantizar
a través del beneficio colectivo y ese
es un criterio muy importante en este
mundo donde los datos son los que tienen
el valor
entonces industria 4.0 no debe dar miedo
esta transición tecnológica no debe
preocuparnos en lo absoluto es algo que
la humanidad ha pasado si se van a
perder empleos cierto pero no pasa nada
también hay estudios muy serios y como
vimos en datos históricos que todas
estas transiciones tecnológicas y en
particular la introducción de robots y
tecnologías similares generan más
empleos que los que desplazan claro a
juan pérez que trabajaba en una línea
pues él va a ser suplantado por un robot
pero cuando uno ve el panorama mayor y
ve toda la sociedad en general se ve
cómo se crean muchos más empleos
entonces pues no tengan miedo de perder
su empleo si lo pierden pues simplemente
hagan lo que siempre hemos hecho como
humanos que es aprender y si alguien es
fan de terminator o matrix cuando creen
que el futuro va a estar dominado por
las máquinas si no va estar dominado por
aquellas personas que decidieron
prepararse y aprender al respecto esta
batalla tecnológica no es contra los
robots no es contra la tecnología
le pese a quien le pese si no esta
batalla es contra uno mismo si uno no
aprende pues quedas obsoleto y pierdes
entonces quiero terminar diciéndoles que
no esperen a que su empleador los vaya a
capacitar y te diga oye ahora ocupas es
no esperes a que tu maestro en la
universidad te enseñe lo que necesitas
para el futuro no esperes a que tu
gobierno ponga leyes y te obliguen a
hacer o aprender tal cosa
no esperes a que la evolución te dé alas
para alcanzar el cielo construye tu
propio bien muchas gracias
[Aplausos]